[Musik]
Ukraine Krieg nachgehakt
herzlich willkommen es sind nur noch
wenige Wochen dann werden wir wohl den
ersten Jahrestag des Krieges Russlands
gegen die Ukraine zu verzeichnen haben
365 Tage Angriffe auf militärische und
zivile Einrichtungen Terror und vor
allem tausende Tote was nicht
eingetreten ist eine von vielen
erwartete schnelle Niederlage der
Ukraine stattdessen zeigt sich das Land
widerstandswillig und fähig auch dank
der Hilfe des Westens und so schrieb
dieser Tage mein heutiger Gast ist
bereitet die Befreiung weitere Gebiete
vor aber auf beiden Seiten werde die
Munition knapper über Munition Logistik
und Kriegsstrategien möchte ich deshalb
sprechen mit dem Politikberater
Politikwissenschaftler und Publizisten
Nico lange erkennt Kiefer erkennt auch
Moskau aus seinerzeit bei der Konrad
Adenauer Stiftung war im leitungsstab
des Bundesverteidigungsministerium sogar
an der Spitze dieses leitungsstabes und
ist jetzt seniorello bei der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz in einem Satz bitte
was macht dein Ziel
bei einem Think Tank arbeitet so
wichtigen Fragen der Zeit und Sie haben
das erwähnt ich spreche fließend
ukrainisch und russisch und arbeite
deshalb viel zu Russland und der Ukraine
ab in beiden Ländern gelebt und es ist
sehr wichtig fragen wie diese hier zu
diskutieren außerdem sind wir mit der
Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz im Land
unterwegs mit seitenwende und Tour und
diskutieren über die Veränderung der aus
und Sicherheitspolitik die ja durch
diesen Krieg ausgelöst worden sind ich
bin auch sicher gekommen über ein Thread
bei Twitter wo sie sich beschäftigt
haben eben mit dem Thema Munition wo
haben Sie Ihre Informationen her was
sind ihre Quellen zu diesem Thema ich
habe immer noch viele Bekannte Freunde
Gesprächspartner in der Ukraine selbst
das sind viele die sich freiwillig
gemeldet haben und jetzt in diesem Krieg
ihr Land verteidigen es gibt eine große
Community die in Telegramm Channels und
mit Open Source intelligence
Informationen Satellitenbilder auswertet
und die Lage verfolgt und die Grundlage
dieser Quellen das ist glaube ich auch
neu in diesem Krieg kann man auch
außerhalb von Institutionen die Lage
sehr genau mitverfolgen und Analysen
anstellen was ist ihre Analyse der
aktuellen Lage des Krieges wir hatten ja
rund um Weihnachten den Jahreswechsel
häufig Angriffe Russlands vor allem auf
Kiew auf die Infrastruktur wie würden
Sie die Lage heute beschreiben jetzt wo
man hört es bereitet sich offenbar vor
allem eine Offensive im Russlands im
Osten des Landes vor Russland versucht
ja schon seit längerem die Stadt bachmut
zu erobern im dornbas und ich glaube es
geht jetzt für Russland sehr stark darum
unbedingt zu beweisen ja wir können noch
etwas erobern nachdem es in einigen
Monaten immer nur rückwärts gegen für
Russland da wird jetzt kein Aufwand
gescheut und da werden auch viele
russische Soldaten und Söldner der
wagnergruppe geopfert um unbedingt
einzunehmen und gleichzeitig sind wir
jetzt in der ersten Woche wo die Böden
richtig festge worden sind in der
Ukraine und wir könnten wieder mehr
Beweglichkeit sehen gerade auch im
Nordosten wo die Ukraine angreift also
wir sind in einer Phase wo beide
Planungen haben wie sie noch
vielversprechender Angriffe machen
könnten wir sind ganz sicher nicht in
einer Phase wo wir uns Verhandlungen
ernähren hat das eine Strategie gegeben
Russlands die immer noch
aufrechterhalten wird oder
wechselstrategie die Strategie
regelmäßig auch auf der Grundlage der
Rückschläge die sich ja durchaus zu
erleiden haben
die politischen Ziele die Putin
formuliert hat also das Auslöschen der
Ukraine die sind weiterhin da aber wie
komme ich dahin ne aber es ist wichtig
dass Putin die Ziele nie angepasst hat
er hat sie erhält sie weiterhin aufrecht
obwohl das jetzt völlig unrealistisch
scheint der russische militärische Plan
mit einer schnellen Eroberung Kiews ist
ganz offensichtlich gescheitert hat zum
einen weil er auf falschen Namen beruhte
und zum anderen dann Widerstand der
Ukraine den sie schon erwähnt haben und
dann hat man glaube ich zwischendurch
auf russischer Seite gedacht jetzt haben
wir ein Rezept gefunden eine Mischung
aus stundenlangen Artillerie Angriffen
und dann langsam vorrücken die
sogenannte Feuerwalze im Osten da hat
man ja auch zwischen April und Juli 60
km Territorium erobern können und
seitdem haben wir aber gesehen die
Ukraine war in der Lage gegen Angriffe
zu entwickeln auch durchzuführen und
konnte die Russen zurückdrängen im
Gebiet ganz im Gebiet und auch bei
Personen und seitdem habe ich den
russland hat eigentlich nicht mehr ein
Rezept wie es in der Ukraine erfolgreich
sein kann kämpft aber weiter und hat mit
Mobilmachung und jetzt neuen
Anstrengungen neue Soldaten zu gewinnen
jetzt vielleicht neue Pläne die gerade
in der Erarbeitung sind aber bisher kann
ich eigentlich nicht erkennen dass
Russland sich noch mal zu neuer Stärke
aufwischen kann und wie dieser Tage zu
lesen und zu hören war offenbar mit
einer weiteren immobilienmachung weil
die die schon mobil gemacht worden sind
offenbar jetzt nicht ausreichen lassen
jetzt gucken auf die Strategie Strategie
der Ukraine die scheint haben sie mit
ihm Vorgespräch gesagt eine ganz
besondere zu sein
die Ukrainer waren sehr gut vorbereitet
und ein bisschen ist es so als wenn die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte gegen sich
selbst von vor zehn Jahren kämpfen ich
will damit sagen die kennen die
russischen Streitkräfte genau und damit
kennen Sie auch die Schwachpunkte genau
haben sich aber selbst weiterentwickelt
haben sich nachzustand als angepasst
haben jüngere militärische Führer auch
in ihren Reihen die kreativer und
eigenständiger Denken und die Ukraine
haben sich darauf verlegt vor allen
Dingen die Logistik und den Nachschub
der Russen anzugreifen die Munition
anzugreifen die Munitionsdepots und den
Nachschub und sind damit sehr
erfolgreich und in einer Armee in der
ist strengi reichlich zugeht wie in der
russischen ist es natürlich auch ein
Erfolgsrezept dass die Ukraine anwenden
immer wieder die führungs- und
Kommunikationseinrichtungen anzugreifen
weil sobald Truppe keine Führung mehr
hat ist sie in Russland nicht in der
Lage selbständig zu denken und auf der
ukrainischen Seite ist eben genau
umgedreht wie wird das möglich dass die
Ukraine da in der Hinsicht so
erfolgreich ist
wie ich schon sagt die Ukraine kennen
die russischen Streitkräfte genau und
wissen wo die Schwachstellen sind und
gleichzeitig wissen wo sie sind also es
gab ja beispielsweise kurz vor Silvester
diesen diesen Fall dass eine russische
Unterkunft massiv angegriffen worden
sind mit vielen Toten wo die Zahlen sehr
weit auseinander gehen irgendwie von
mehreren hundert die Rede bis immerhin
hat Russland rund 90 glaube ich
eingestanden aber da muss natürlich
erstmal wissen wo die sind sie haben
recht wenn man diesen ukrainischen Stil
sondern nicht das mal kämpfen will dann
braucht man Mobilität man braucht
Präzision und man braucht sehr gut
Aufklärungsergebnisse und von Anfang an
hatte die Ukraine eine sehr gute
Einschätzung der Situation sehr gute
Bilder da haben sicherlich auch Partner
der Ukraine die USA aber übrigens auch
die EU mit Satellitenbildern geholfen
vor allen Dingen setzen die Ukraine aber
auch Drohnen ein das ist auch etwas in
diesem Krieg aus dem wir lernen müssen
in welcher Masse in Deutschland werden
in welcher Masse dort Drohnen eingesetzt
werden um Lagebild zu gewinnen und die
Arena sind exzellent in der Lage die
Daten aus allen Quellen zusammenzuführen
und mit diesen Daten zu arbeiten und das
sind ja dann nicht nur die Drohnen und
die Satellitenbilder das sind ja zum
Beispiel auch die Mobiltelefone der
Ukrainerinnen Ukrainer wo jede Oma und
jeder Oper am Straßenrand am Anfang
haben wir das gesehen im Krieg auch die
russischen truppenfotografiert hat und
die Bilder weitergeschickt hat so dass
die lokalisiert werden konnten und
genutzt werden konnten von Militär
gleichwohl haben sie in dem von mir
schon erwähnten Fred bei Twitter gesagt
es der Ukraine geht die Munition aus wo
ist das Problem bei der Logistik was
Munition angeht je länger der Krieg
dauert desto wichtiger werden die
industriellen Fragen und da geht's eben
nicht nur um die Frage hat man einen
Waffensystem sondern es geht um die
Frage kann ich dieses Waffensystem immer
wieder und immer wieder mit neuem
Munition versorgen und die Russen haben
insbesondere für Artillerie sie sind ja
eine Armee die sehr stark mit Artillerie
arbeitet fast unendliche Vorräte an
Munition gehabt also unfassbar viel
Artillerie Munition haben sie
verschossen und auch immer wieder neue
kommen und die Ukrainer hatten zum
Anfang ihre eigene Artillerie die
ersetzt werden musste durch Artillerie
nach NATO Standard mit einem anderen
Kaliber damit dann auch Munition
nachgeschoben werden kann man muss sich
vor Augen führen die Ukraine verbraucht
aber an einem Tag mehr
Artilleriemunition als mehrere
europäische Staaten zusammen überhaupt
im Monat produzieren also das ist nicht
nur die Frage liefert man Munition an
die Ukraine sondern es wird immer mehr
zur Frage sind wir in der Lage Munition
zu produzieren um sie in die Ukraine zu
liefern aber bei dem Bedarf den sie
gerade genannt haben ist es doch fast
ausgeschlossen
Putin rechnet und wenn er die Rechnung
aufmacht er kann uns
ausproduzieren indem er mehr Artillerie
Munition produziert als wir dann wird er
glauben dass er den Krieg gewinnen kann
insofern ist ja die Frage stellen wir
die Produktion um starten wir mehr
munitionsproduktion auch eine Frage der
Kommunikation an Putin ja wir sind
entschlossen wir tun alles was notwendig
ist damit die Ukraine sich durchsetzen
kann in diesem Krieg Carlo Masala der
verteidigungsexperte den sie natürlich
auch kennen der hat der Süddeutschen
Zeitung gesagt hier wird versuchen die
Logistik der russischen Armee so zu
schwächen dass die Front kollabiert ist
das realistisch das ist realistisch das
passt zu der Kampfweise die wir
besprochen haben wenn doch wie sie
gerade sagen die Munition knapp und
knapp wird die Kampfweise der Ukraine
ist genau darauf ausgerichtet und wir
haben bei reson gesehen das genau das
gelungen ist man hat ja die Kräfte dort
auf dem südwestlichen Ufer des nepro von
ukrainischer Seite gar nicht direkt
bekämpft sondern man hat sie
abgeschnitten von Munition und Nachschub
und dann hat es von August bis November
gedauert bis die Russen diesen
Frontabschnitt aufgeben mussten also die
Methode funktioniert aber sie haben
Recht die Methode kann nur funktionieren
wenn die Partner der Ukraine ständig
Munition nachliefern und wenn die
Ukraine nicht gezwungen ist zum Beispiel
zu priorisieren an welchen
Frontabschnitten sie überhaupt noch
kämpfen können oder irgendwelche Ziele
sie überhaupt noch schießen können tun
das die Partner wie sich eben
angesprochen haben im ausreichenden Maß
also insbesondere die Vereinigten
Staaten aber viele andere Partner haben
da viel getan aber es wird eben jetzt
weniger zur Frage wer kann noch etwas
liefern weil eben so viel schon
verbraucht worden ist und es wird zu der
Frage wer produziert für die Ukraine
diese Munition und da ist noch nicht
ausreichend getan worden wer kann da
noch was tun und was müsste was konkret
fehlt wir haben große Industrienationen
in Europa eine davon ist Deutschland
aber sicherlich auch Frankreich Italien
Spanien es gibt
moderne Produktionsanlagen ich glaube
auch für westliche Moderne Staaten
sollte es möglich sein auch kurzfristig
solche Aufträge zu geben und die
Munition zu produzieren aber es braucht
natürlich finanzielle Garantien für die
Unternehmen die das machen und die die
Investitionsentscheidungen treffen
müssen und es wäre besser wenn das eher
schneller ging als langsamer wissen Sie
denn darüber ob die tun die das
Idee daran versuchen die das aufzuholen
das Defizit das da ist
das wird daran gearbeitet aber nach
meiner Auffassung nicht in ausreichendem
Maße was braucht die Ukraine noch jetzt
haben wir immer Munition gesprochen wir
haben dieser Tage gehört dass Frankreich
später Panzer liefert dass Deutschland
Schützenpanzer liefern will wo ja lange
schon darauf hingearbeitet worden ist
jetzt endlich die Entscheidung gefallen
was braucht die Ukraine noch in nächster
Zukunft wir haben über Munition
gesprochen wir haben auch über Drohnen
gesprochen von beiden braucht die
Ukraine so viel wie möglich
und was die Schützenpanzer und
Kampfpanzer betrifft ist schon lange
klar dass die Ukraine damit sie Russland
aus dem Land bringen kann und die
russische Front durchbrechen kann
mechanisierte Kräfte braucht und das ist
eine Kombination aus Kampfpanzern und
Schützenpanzern ich würde auch erwarten
jetzt wo man endlich das Richtige tut
nachdem im Frühsommer viele ukrainische
Soldaten gestorben sind im
Artilleriefeuer den ich hätten sterben
müssen nachdem im Herbst aus meiner
Sicht eine Chance verpasst worden ist wo
die Ukraine hätte angreifen können aber
die mechanisierten Kräfte nicht hatte
würde ich erwarten dass man jetzt das
richtige sehr schnell tut und möglichst
alles was man kann und da gehören aus
meiner Sicht die Schützenpanzer und die
Kampfpanzer zusammen aber wahrscheinlich
wird das noch ein bisschen dauern oder
es gibt immer zwei Maßstäbe es gibt den
Maßstab haben wir schon viel getan das
ist auf jeden Fall richtig Deutschland
hat sich weit bewegt und viel getan aber
es gibt auch den anderen Maßstab was ist
denn militärisch notwendig und dem
Soldaten in bachmut nützt es ja wenig
wenn man ihm sagt ja Deutschland hat
doch aber schon viel getan der hat
entweder das was er braucht oder hat es
nicht
guck mal ein bisschen auf die nächsten
Monate vielleicht der britische
Historiker ihren kehrshow hat in der
Süddeutschen Zeitung wieder vermutet der
Krieg sein in einem halben Jahr zu Ende
und der begründet das damit dass bei der
Grad der zum möhrung sagt er gesagt auf
beiden Seiten nur noch schwer zu
ertragen ist jetzt kommt der Winter dazu
und entscheidend sei deshalb ist die
Ukraine im Frühjahr mit westlicher
Unterstützung zu einer neuen Offensive
gegen ihre Angreifer bereit und in der
Lage was denken sie
also die Ukraine hat den Willen nicht
nur als Streitkräfte sondern auch als
Gesellschaft
ob sie die militärischen Möglichkeiten
dazu hast das ist eine Frage der
Ausstattung und auch der Unterstützung
durch uns also wir sind ja da keine
Beobachter wir können ja dazu beitragen
dass die Ukraine diese Möglichkeiten hat
ob es dann auch die Chance dazu gibt das
ist von der Entwicklung der Lage an der
frontabhängig da muss die Ukraine
Möglichkeiten ergreifen wenn sie sich
bieten das kann man so nicht vorhersagen
aber mein Eindruck ist die Ukraine hat
auf jeden Fall militärische Planung die
Russen komplett vom Staatsgebiet der
Ukraine wieder zu entfernen sie hat dazu
auch alles recht inklusive Creme
die Krim haben wir nicht anerkannt als
Staatsgebiete Ukraine also ich rede vom
Staat haben um die quasi zurückzuerobern
wenn man so will der Russland wird sich
ja nicht freiwillig zurückziehen also
ich habe den Eindruck militärisch ist
die Krim nicht schwieriger
möglicherweise sogar einfacher als zum
Beispiel
befestigte Stellung der Russen im
dornbuz ist eine relativ isolierte
Halbinsel mit wenigen Zugängen aber die
Ukraine hat völkerrechtlich glaube ich
eine völlig korrekte Position wenn sie
sagt wir wollen dass die Ukraine in den
Grenzen von 1991 am Ende dieses Krieges
steht wenn ist der Krieg zu Ende ihrer
Meinung nach dann wenn alle russischen
Truppen die Ukraine verlassen haben und
das ist dann ungefähr wann
Wissen über die über die militärischen
Möglichkeiten die beide Seiten haben ich
habe den Eindruck im Moment haben beide
Seiten militärische Planung bis zum Ende
des nächsten Sommers
aber wir sind ja keine Beobachter der
Krieg geht schneller zu Ende wenn wir
der Ukraine das liefert was braucht dann
hoffen wir alle das Beste nikolange
vielen Dank dass Sie heute bei uns
gewesen sind und Ihnen meine Damen und
Herren danke fürs zusehen
[Musik]